hellstrom's first bloody season is
available on hulu and we've had the
chance to watch all 10 episodes
while the first season purposefully ends
with some pretty big questions
we're getting the jump on the season's
conclusion to answer as many of those
queries
as possible in mother's little helpers
hellstrom's premiere episode
chris yen wants as little as possible to
do with the darker side
of his employer's life anna is his boss
and while chris seems to know about
anna's abilities and the fact that she
uses them to execute violent men too
rich and powerful for the law to
constrain
he seems very happy sticking to the more
mundane side of anna's business
do you have any idea how much damage
control i've been doing
five times i've texted you five times i
didn't answer
unfortunately due in no small part to
chris's curiosity
by the end of hellstrom's first season
he doesn't have much of a choice
chris is possessed early in the series
and by the penultimate episode vessels
he believes he's been freed of all
mystical influence
however when chris removes his bandages
after noticing the blood leaking through
them
he sees symbols carved into his arm and
even more disturbing
a giant eyeball emerging from his throat
a panicked visit with the caretaker
reveals that chris's experiences
have turned him into a keeper a guardian
tasked with the guardianship of demons
you call the home office tell them i
quit
christian is no one's keeper in the
season finale chris knows important
things without knowing why he's able to
give anna the knowledge that helps her
save her brother though as we'll see
he doesn't know quite as much as he
thinks keeper's intuition
okay you've been a keeper for like two
seconds and i'm not happy about it
now that he's become a keeper chris
tells anna the only way to save her
brother damon who's been possessed and
is working with the other demons is to
reforge her father's mystical knife
no one gives the weapon a name but we
know that it's the same instrument that
scarred damon's chest
and the only weapon that succeeded in
leaving any kind of mark on him
taking the relic with them into one of
the padded cells of saint teresa's
together allah and victoria embrace and
use their power to remake the blade
once we see it in use we see it's
hellstrom's version of the fiery trident
daemon's comic book counterpart
is almost never seen without while
tussling with the possessed damon anna
is able to extend the knife into its
true powerful form
with it damon and anna are able to
achieve something rarely seen on the
show
stabbing a possessed person with the
trident exercises the demon from them
without killing the person
damon and anna are both able to do this
on their own in the series but at a
greater physical cost to themselves and
not nearly as quickly
you wouldn't be blamed for assuming dr
june hastings wouldn't make it to the
end of hellstrom's first season
not only is she part of a team making
war with the forces of darkness
but early in the series we get hints
that she's not well eventually our
suspicions are confirmed when she
reveals that she's dying of lung cancer
the writers play with our expectations
setting hastings up as the obvious
sacrificial lamb
particularly in vessels when she tells a
caretaker that she has changed her mind
and decided to undergo the difficult
treatments necessary to fight the cancer
it comes as little surprise when in the
series finale she's stabbed from behind
with a fireplace poker
she survives the stabbing but scares
everyone when all of the devices
surrounding her hospital bed
start their alarms and doctors and
nurses rush to her bed
surprisingly enough she pulls through
although she's far from unscathed
after she wakes up in the hospital the
caretaker tells her the doctors had to
remove one of her kidneys and part of
her lung
but she survives possibly to once again
help the hellstrom's battle demons in
future seasons
in hellstorm the hellstrom season 1
finale anna is forced to fight her
brother in order to save him
taking their cue from the joker the
possessed damon and the other demons
use an abandoned carnival as their base
of operations it's there that they bring
the pregnant gabriella hoping she'll
soon give birth to the demon mother and
die herself soon afterward
wandering into an old haunted house anna
finds a possessed damon waiting for her
with similar telekinetic abilities and
strength the two are evenly matched
though the possessed damon has the
advantage as unlike anna he's looking to
kill not to save
come on fight it
well neither anna nor damon's comic book
counterparts are the most visible of
marvel's heroes usually if one of them
is saving the day in a comic book it's
damon
but here the tables get turned it's anna
who saves her brother by unveiling the
mystical knife in its full glory
extending it into a fiery trident and
stabbing her brother with it from behind
nothing about damon's reaction seems
very pleasant but thankfully the weapon
drives a demon from him and gives him
back control of himself
at the end of underneath episode 8 both
damon and gabriella are possessed by
demons with the goal of conceiving a new
form for the demon mother
in vessels and hellstorm we see
gabriella go from newly pregnant to
close to labor in a single night
while both gabriella and her colleagues
consider finding a way to terminate the
pregnancy
the baby is born to gabriela in the
season one finale
though thankfully anna and damon are
able to intervene and save gabriella
before the demons can complete their
plan by cutting her throat
at first it seems like no one is even
sure if mother's plan to be reborn
worked all of the heroes including chris
with his new keeper abilities
seem to believe there is nothing strange
or mystical about the child
but that changes fairly quickly while
the rest of the heroes gather for a
celebratory dinner
the camera pans for the baby's crib but
she's missing without
explanation one month later we see chris
about to board a ferry with a young girl
he calls lily
the implication seems to be that this is
the girl gabriella gave birth to
that it was chris who abducted her from
her crib and just as gabriella's
pregnancy happened in record time
her aging process has sped up lily
appears to be at least six or seven
years old and if we doubt this is
supposed to be the same child
what happens next confirms it of all of
hellstrom's regular characters no one is
more changed by the events of the series
than gabriella
in the beginning of season 1 while
gabriella is certainly more naive about
the world of the supernatural than
veterans like damon and the caretaker
she's no fool even after being
confronted by some of the darkest things
heroes like damon and anna are capable
of
she still sees the good in them but the
events of the episodes that follow make
her lose faith in her friends
after giving birth and being saved from
the demons who kidnapped her
gabriella makes it clear to damon she
wants nothing to do with him when damon
visits her in the hospital she refers to
demons as
your kind and tells damon she believes
she's being punished for wanting to be
intimate with him in underneath
gabriella is the focus of one of the
more surprising scenes toward the end of
the season finale we see gabriella
drinking with members of the blood
when she first encounters the
organization earlier in the series
and learns of how they keep possessed
people in comas for the rest of their
lives to keep the demons within them in
prison for as long as they can
she's disgusted by their methods now it
looks like she's a card-carrying recruit
season finale hellstrom opens with a
flashback in which we see a young damon
hellstrom
try to leave everything behind damon as
a young boy looks over the edge of a
bridge
clearly contemplating something serious
predictably damon leaps from the bridge
but inches from the water an invisible
force stops him a spectral voice tells
him you'll always be my son
and the same force that saved him throws
him clear of the water
by the end of the season finale damon
seems to once again
feel the weight of the world on his
shoulders he returns to the same bridge
and peers over the side
presumably either contemplating his past
suicide attempt
considering a repeat performance or both
but thankfully damon finds enough to
keep living for the scene cuts to damon
standing at the edge of the water where
he's soon joined by
anna they share a rare touching moment
as much as damon has been through in
this first season of hellstrom and it's
a lot
he's found enough to hold on to in order
to keep going i love you
you know that
i do in the closing moments of hellstrom
we get a look at a villain who's been
with us the whole season
though we still know little about him
the unnamed father of damon and anna
intercepts chris and the young lily as
they're about to board a ferry
at first lily doesn't seem to have any
idea who the bald man is
but when he asks her to remember lily
smiles and calls him papa
though he's intimidated by him chris has
no intention of turning over lily
earlier in the episode he has anna mark
him with her father's knife and this
appears to be why chris tells papa
hellstrom that he can't hurt chris
because he's been marked by his
bloodline
the father stares at him darkly and soon
the other people waiting for the ferry
one by one begin to drop
chris is apparently right that papa
hellstrom can't hurt him
so instead he starts killing everyone
else horrified chris let's go with lily
papa hellstrom leaves with a girl as the
people waiting for the ferry to continue
to drop
in the source material damon hellstrom
was originally introduced on comic book
covers
as the son of satan so far in hellstrom
it hasn't been made clear exactly who
his father is
but whoever he is this final scene makes
it clear he's no run-of-the-mill demon
and he'll likely be back for any future
seasons check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you